welcome to this video playing male Oh
Milo my yellow from from Greece they are
playing accelerated the accelerated
dragon type of setup this is a good line
against that hmm might have six yeah I
forgot I forgot the exact move on the CM
Nigeria to go here
yeah I have a very good development the
night on a three can join on be 501c4
it's not clear what it's night on g4s
doing hmm yeah what next just um just
develop or is age 3 a good move to make
sure the night is going through the edge
and not for the f6 here yeah maybe here
also awesome i bet preventing the f porn
from moving chat soon oh no i didn't see
that one didn't see that one coming but
is it good is it good no I'm not sure
what exactly is this point he wants to
take the porn yeah probably yeah Queenie
to is not so convincing really and King
f1
I can really take the poll after that
some pretty forward to move I really
should have thought about that yeah it
should really just keep it simple why
not play h3 and get this night on the
edge then black is just just worse
forever really unnecessary Jim Jeff it's
it's not not great but what what should
I do check now it's gotten cut knight c6
in I'd everything makes sense ok yeah it
always feels a bit bit bad too this is
really an almost incorrect opening I
know that some GM's play it but it's not
really good with Queen see 593 widest
really better okay yeah now he is in
perfect the perfect shape again yeah you
can take e5 if i take be five at the end
i love life cap bishop f3 now that's
fortunate there should be hard for p8
but Bishop is good how does he save the
rock now well that's funny
yeah that's that's a lucky turn of
events
ok but then let's be precise now not the
law before
yeah how to do that i mean what i need
to get i need to exchange the bishop
this is helping it enormously yeah
getting getting the King to 12 b 3 as a
good plan yeah I can I can freeze up the
King side that's not a bad idea I always
have at the end of all this i have the B
point to check with a forehand and move
like that okay
hmm that's not bad at all with the edge
porn he cannot move you cannot movie 5
that's a that's important of course so g
15 g for maybe a young king g4 ok he
wants to play five after all so let's
see
yeah okay I mean I have some play with
the Jeep own as well
check
checking here is going to e Phi of him
what about g6 by taking d5 yeah maybe
I'm just forcing this the same nice got
f3 f3 ah time morning every and you see
it of course instantly after you play it
this is giving him just the temple my
very important temple check chairman
look you one yeah like you cannot defend
this with 2 12 seconds now that's really
bad check cam king of fibers of course a
complete jammin but it's probably too
late
okay please the drone with seven seconds
on the clock game drawn my man oh man oh
man oh man yeah runs right Brooke g5 how
stupid can you play I mean running right
into f3 completely unnecessary Imbruglia
this this year check it's just a win for
fun fun and easy relatively easy i pick
up the pants here get the e pawn
something like that he needs to retreat
because of mate then i can even just
take him then it doesn't matter really
this i have the king near the pawns this
wins very easily when i run right into
the stupid III yeah i mean it was it was
it wasn't good technical flavor me
anyway i didn't i didn't need to allow
him him to get the pawns could have done
that much easier and this also took two
ends this is even better probably I hear
this this is strong didn't didn't see
that one
ok this is computer chess getting for
getting to to a meeting attack I
couldn't couldn't really see that it's
plus 5 so but I mean what I really
shouldn't do is I shouldn't really allow
this kind of stuff and get it I mean
it's probably from a technical point of
view I'm really good because it's
winning but it really should be a purely
technical affair so maybe just f4 here
this just just ignore this and play
technical play technical game now we
will never get any kind of passer and
this will be relatively easy to play
without any tactics you have this as
much item it really it's much easier to
play the better tactic technical
solution you can never push anyporn him
and dumb you can just you can just sit
and wait and then I can slowly try to
improve let's say here and here
intending g4 if he takes I get on the H
file and I mean this is a very easy win
with one pair of rooks off as I just go
to the beep on or or get a pass on the
queenside it's um I played it far too
complicated thanks for watching